done
はぁんっ
はぁんっん
[音楽]
ん
me
いいいい
i am
ana
p ん
いいいい
yeah yeah
me
ana
aname
me
ana
いいいいいい
ええええええええええええ
ana
いいいいいいい
wh
ええええええ
n ame
[音楽]
[拍手]
me
[音楽]
[拍手]
can
きっき
tan
yeah yeah
me
ええええええ
wh
car
いいいいいいい
cane
ええええええ
me
[音楽]
ana
me
ええええええ
ane
いいいいいいいいいい
me
[音楽]
[拍手]
me
ええええええ
[拍手]
ani
yeah yeah
ええええええ
me
yeah yeah
[音楽]
ええええええ
yeah yeah
[音楽]
wh
ええええええ
ane
me
いいいい
[音楽]
いいいいいい
me
[音楽]
[笑い]
me
[音楽]
ana
ええええええ
tan
[拍手]
ran
ええええええ
ana
n ame
[拍手]
me
[音楽]
[拍手]
ana
ha
me
aname
[音楽]
[拍手]
yeah yeah
me
[音楽]
tan tan
me
いいいい
[拍手]
[音楽]
tan
me
ana
dare
[音楽]
[拍手]
wh
he
ええええええ
[音楽]
me
いいいい
tan
いいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいいい
cane
いいいい
ana
b 美
panhead
どうですかあっはぁっ
a ばあちゃん派を教えちゃんは者損英語している家へんやんちんと10日んじゃ
初めまして私は神戸華僑総会星タイの老犬亮と申しますよろしくお願いします
はあああああ
あの
a た場合の観ていただいたのは中国のほうでも南方系の cc ぬ何周と言います
日本の獅子舞と違って獣の場所はちょっと一回り大きかったりですとかが肝
太鼓ドラシーン丸と非常ににぎやかな音で構成されています
言われとしましても日本の姉妹同様に獣に噛まれると無病息災商売繁盛と非常にゲンを
担ぐ祝いの舞とされています
ちょっと線埼京も中野
ほどの方々すみませんか見に行けなくて
この獅子舞なんですけれども我々援助をですねこの獅子頭を単に
かぶって踊ってるだけではなくて実は基本的な動作というのが
やつあります我々でいますっぱーたいと言っています
その奴の状態なんですけれども
喜怒哀楽聖堂競技
という風にへ
基本の動作がやつあります今日は比較的ダイナミックな演技を中心としているんです
けれども
獅子舞無実はストーリー性を持たせた演武というのが多くございますそこで獅子が
例えば好物のものを探しに行きましてその好物を見つけた時にちょっとどんな味がする
のか楽しみになったりだとか
それを取るに至るまでに行こう
星の動き道の動きを含めたりでそれを本当に食べれるのかと疑ったりとか
匂い嗅いでちょっと驚いてみたいとかそういった基本的な動作を習得した上で演者
それぞれが個性を出し合って表現をそういう工夫しているところです
こんなし終えとを私との出会いというのは私がちょっと5歳のときです
8私はこの日本の神戸で生まれて育ってきた中国国籍を持つか凶と言われる
そして私は賛成にあたりますおじいちゃんおばあちゃん
そしてお父さんお母さんへて私がいて賛成にあたります
一昔前ですとかケア同士の結婚式とか
委員会でこの中国し終えて非常に多く
呼ばれて四肢を舞うことがたくさんありました
そこで私もその初めて見たときに大きくなったらいつかこれがしたいなぁと思う気持ち
がありまして
高校生の時にこの隊に入隊しましたそしてときは断って伊豆ないかちょっと隊長を任せ
られるようになりましてそこでどんどん年を重ねるごとにこの獅子舞の楽しさというか
魅力
に知ることができました先ほどの皆さんにお話したパータイムをその内の1つなんです
けれども
あっ単純に動いているのではなくてししてこういう楽しい所があるんだっていうのを
知ってただ
ここ頭で活動していく中国地震前なんですけれども本土の方に行けば敢闘賞ですとか
台湾書とか
隣国で言うとシンガポールマレーシア
そういったところでも実は中国獅子舞ですね非常に
庶民に密着していてシュごく当たり前のように姉妹が行われているんです
世界大会まであるぐらいなんです
ただやはりここ日本でこの中国獅子舞をやっていくうえでなかなかあそこまで認知度と
いうのが低くてですね
我々か今日の中においているのですねえっとその中国4しま
認識っていうのがなくてというのも我々賛成
もしくはこの構成4整合性になってきますとやはり日本社会で住んでいるものなので
8 d 合う方は日本の方が非常に多いですし
結婚するの日本の方と結婚することが多いので結婚式にそんなし島を呼ぶという認識は
ほとんど今
なくなってきているんですねなので我々ももっともっとこの
中国獅子舞というのを広めたいけれどもなかなか
か今日の中でもそれが転生していけない続けていけないというジレンマを抱えることに
なっていました
ただ
そこで
海外の方と出会うきっかけがありまして
他の団体を見ていますと別に架橋にこだわらないで獅子舞をずっと続けられている方々
団体がたくさん多くありました
私もそこで改めて自分が何書こうか今日中国籍とかそういうのにこだわってた自分が
ちょっと違うんじゃないかなと思いました
というのもここ僕は神戸で生まれ育って頭というのはもうもちろんあればのような中国
系のものもいれば
韓国の方だったり
インドの方だったり欧米の方だったり本当に異国民が一つの街で共存する
そんなマジなんだなということを知って
いろんな出演先で皆さんにこの中国し島を知ってもらうだけではなくてそこで知り合っ
た人たち興味を持った人たちに門戸を広げて
頭らしく
国際色豊かなメンバーがこの神戸華僑総会星たいとして共に一つの伝統文化伝統芸能を
一緒に
高専伝承継承していってもいいのではないかなと思うようになりました
最後にへ
影響を見ていただいてあっ楽しかったとか喘いと噛まれて嬉しかったという方もおら
れると思いますがもしこの中に一人でも
もしくは2人でも興味を持っていただいてやってみたいという人がおられれば是非我々
と一緒に一つの
伝統文化伝統芸能伝承者となって一緒に担い手となっていただければと思います
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]